but first my brain done
what is forgiveness i mean put simply
it's normally about accepting that
somebody made a mistake they're sorry
about that mistake
and we agree not to hold it against them
going forward so should we forgive
prince andrew the archbishop of
canterbury the most senior religious
leader in britain suggested that we
should mark the queen's platinum jubilee
by well doing that
with prince andrew
i think we all have to
step back a bit
he's
seeking to
make amends
and i think that's a very good thing
but is he seeking to make amends or is
prince andrew seeking to repair his
battered reputation
and try and retain some semblance of
relevance in public life
if forgiveness is accepting that someone
made a mistake we need to know what
mistake prince andrew believes he made
there are plenty to choose from was a
heaping global embarrassment on his
mother the queen and the monarchy was it
remaining close friends with pedophile
jeffrey epstein after he admitted and
was convicted
of child abuse
was he giving the most toe-curling
interview in royal history which he
ridiculously claimed that a meal with a
pizza restaurant and his inability to
sweat proved his innocence
this grand old duke of york has had ten
thousand excuses
now prince andrew said he would fight to
clear his name
when virginia jeffrey accused him of
sexually assaulting at the age of 17.
then at the very last minute
he didn't do that he didn't go to court
instead he wrote a massive check
to mr frey to settle things
i would say that forgiveness starts with
explaining why he did that
why would you give millions of dollars
to somebody if you believe you did
nothing wrong and in fact you never even
met that person
all we've seen from prince andrew is i'm
going to clear my name
followed by actually i'm writing a big
fat check for this to go away that's not
acceptance or repentance
and i'm sorry but i think the public
might find the forgiveness part that the
archbishop of canterbury is suggesting
very hard without them
we're talking of disgraced men who may
or may not need national redemption he's
run out of excuses he's running out of
friends is boris johnson now running out
of time
the british prime minister's had a
turbulent premiership with a pandemic
the illegal lockdown party scandal and
now ruinous inflation but his ferocious
friendly fire from his own tory mps now
doing the worst damage and i believe it
will be politically fatal 28 johnson's
own conservative members of parliament
have now publicly called for him to quit
if 54 of them write letters of no
confidence he'll face a vote that may
have been packing his bags at number 10.
and frankly i think he should
tonight his own ethics advisor said that
the ministerial code the bible of
standards for the most powerful people
in the country faces ridicule because
johnson won't admit
if he broke it
how much more condemnation can one man
sustain boris johnson's whole brand has
been built on bluster blather and bull
that and making people laugh
and they didn't get away with that in
the good times but when times get tough
none of it seems quite so funny anymore
when people are dying
losing their jobs can't find the money
to feed their children
and especially when voters discover that
the man who locked them down for several
years
was a shameless hypocrite parting it up
in downing street with his staff
i've got my own letter to the prime
minister it's a very short one
dear boris
the party's over
resign
universities used to be places where
students were keen to broaden their
minds by hearing different views
now they're becoming seething woke
hotbeds of vicious violent intolerance
the latest target was british education
secretary nadim zahawi visiting warwick
university in the midlands
charming people
yeah a furious mob of howling students
hounded the harvey off the campus
hurling abuse at him and in one case
physically hitting a member of the
conservative association who invited him
and what was his crime exactly well the
protesters accused him of inciting
hatred by defining a woman as an adult
human female
that's not hatred that's a simple
biological fact
what the hell is going on at our
universities there's now a sort of
complete intolerance of free speech
among many of these students who've been
apparently brainwashed by the canceled
culture mentality
they need to realize in the real world
not everybody will agree with them and
if they want to live in the kind of
tolerant society that they constantly
preach about
well they could start by tolerating
other people's opinions
especially when like mr zahawi
those opinions happen to be correct
now a public service broadcast for our
friends across the pond it's the
americans guide to the queen's platinum
jubilee which you'll be hearing so much
about in the next few days
now the jubilee is when brits celebrate
our monarch the monarch is well like a
president only without the politics or
the power which is why we tend to like
and unlike other royal events which
celebrate change coronations weddings
funerals
a jubilee celebrates the lack of change
namely that the monarch is still alive
if that doesn't sound like much only six
of our monarchs have ever made it to a
golden jubilee for 50 years on the
throne only two made it to their diamond
jubilee for 60 and only one
her majesty our current monarch has ever
gone platinum after 70 years in the
hottest seat imaginable
and we celebrate all this with massive
street parties
because well they're free and everyone
gets too drunk to drive home anyway like
the queen it often rains over us we
don't care about the weather we hang up
something called bunting which are
little paper flags tied to lampposts
because well i don't know because we've
always hung bunting we eat sandwiches
cucumber normally we drink tea yorkshire
gold is my preference and victoria
sponge which is a big cake named after
another monarch
i'll also be attending the cricket at
lords because that's what we do as well
and if all this seems a little bit
strange to you in america especially
when there's so much very serious stuff
going on well frankly for the next few
days we don't care because we get to
have four days off the pubs are open
late and we love
our queen
and says the next does the letters of no
confidence continue to pile up is it
time to say bye bye boris
and later the world's most outspoken
uncensored human being former sex
bitters frontman john lydon aka johnny
roth